okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about midpoint so midpoint is definitely
something you want to know for the a c t
let's go over the formula and we'll go
through some examples so the midpoint
formula is x 1 plus x 2 divided by 2 and
y 1 plus y 2 divided by 2. so it's like
an average you're adding the x
coordinates of the two points the two
endpoints and dividing by two and then
you're adding the y coordinates of the
two points and divided by two and that's
how you find the middle or the average
so for example here if we have the
points one four
and 3 8 okay i just kind of draw a
diagram like this we're trying to find
the midpoint 1 plus 3 is 4 divided by 2
and 4 plus 8 is 12 divided by 2 so you
can see this is going to be 2 comma 6
is the location of the midpoint so let's
do a couple examples go ahead and pause
the video so you can practice on your
own and then we can go ahead and do
these together so and check your answer
if m is the midpoint of segment bc and
the coordinates of point b are 2
negative 6 and the coordinates of point
m okay are a negative one and negative
nine what are the coordinates of point c
that's the other endpoint
so see if you can do that one on your
own so the way i would do this is i
would draw kind of like a diagram
something like this okay so here's your
midpoint here's b here's c right we
don't know the coordinates of c so let's
call that x y
b they tell us the coordinates are 2
negative 6 and the midpoint negative 1
negative 9. now don't worry about this
drawing being you know
accurate as far as in the coordinate
plane this is just to help us to
visualize so we know the midpoint but we
don't know the end point so what you
would do is you would add the two
endpoints together so we'd say
x plus 2 divided by 2
okay so the average of the x's equals
negative 1 and then the average of the
y's
y plus negative 6 divided by 2 equals
the y-coordinate of the midpoint
all you have to do then is solve these
little mini equations uh by multiplying
let's see both sides by 2 so that's x
plus 2 equals negative 2. subtract 2
from both sides you get x equals
negative 4. same thing here multiply
both sides by 2.
that gives you y minus 6 and then if you
add 6 to both sides you get negative 12.
so you can see your answer is going to
be negative 4 or negative 12.
and if you want to double check your
work just go ahead and add these
together and divide by 2. so negative 4
plus 2 is negative 2 divided by 2 is
negative one and so on
let's go to example number two
so if your school is two blocks east and
four blocks north of your home and your
gym is three blocks west and two blocks
south of your home and your favorite
restaurant is halfway between your gym
and school
where is the restaurant located in
relation to your house so see if you can
do this problem on your own and we'll do
it together
so the first thing that i would do here
is i would
draw a coordinate axis system so i would
like coordinateize these
locations turn them into coordinates and
you can
draw this as north east
south
west so north east southwest like so and
so basically let's say your house is
right here at the origin and you're
going two blocks east and four blocks
north so two east
and four north so there's two comma four
and that represents let's see your
school right so i'll just put s for
school and then your gym is three blocks
west and two uh two blocks south right
so one two three
and two south so that's at negative
three negative two that's the gym right
okay and your favorite restaurant is
halfway between
the gym and the school okay so we're
basically looking for the midpoint so
when they say halfway notice they didn't
come right out and tell us it was the
midpoint but halfway is is midway right
so all we're going to do is use our
midpoint formula we're going to add
negative 3 plus 2 divided by 2 so i'm
adding the x coordinates together and
dividing by 2
okay same thing with the y's we've got 4
plus negative 2 divided by 2
and that's our midpoint so that's going
to be negative 1 half
and this is going to be two over two
which is one
now in the context of this problem in
relation to your home that's going to be
a half a block west
in one block north so i'll just say one
half
block
west
and one
block
north
and that would be your solution so this
is a little tricky problem about this is
that you just had to coordinate the
points draw this northeast southwest
axis so that you could locate
where those were in relation to your
home and you placed your home at the
origin but after you got it
coordinatized as such using the midpoint
formula was straight pretty
straightforward so midpoint's definitely
something you want to know for the ect
memorize that formula and i'll see in
the next lesson